what's the best part of the school
dinner you remember i feel like i know
what you're going to say because i i
feel like
what reminds me of you let's say like
turkey twizzlers or something no no no
no what reminded me of this was because
we went uh
there's like a local bar near us and
it's like i don't even know how to
describe
what this like what the theme of this
bar is right
um this this bar that we go to that has
just like the most random assortment of
foods
you could think it's all good it's all
great uh and so we ordered this like i
can't remember what we ordered but we
ordered like
some dish and what comes out is the
[ __ ] smiley potato chips
that's right those things are so good
they taste so good i can't remember what
dish we ordered but i remember we came
we
came out and like the three of us just
reverted back to being like
seven years old being like we're all
just like potato chips
you know this is what it looks like if
you didn't have it wherever you grew up
it's basically just the funimation logo
it has like a taste that is so unique
yeah because it's not it's not just
it's not fried it's it's not fries it's
not like potatoes it's just got such a
unique taste
and i'm sure anyone who didn't grow up
with it would think it tastes like [ __ ]
or i could be a billionaire and i'll be
like charles
heat up the smiley faces won't you bring
in the smiley face ever since i saw
those at that restaurant i've been
trying to find them they're so good
like i can't find them anywhere because
they don't sell them in like
supermarkets
because i like because because it's it's
like it's so bizarre because like
the restaurant i wouldn't call it posh
but it's like it's like uh the decor
is extremely nice very i'd say it's very
almost very
it's very humbling yeah it's it's it's
very nice it's it's not it's okay it's
everywhere yeah
so i'm just i'm just i just laughed
right because they bring out this dish
and they were just probably like
this is imported potato from britain
enjoy lads and i'm just thinking here
this is just school dinner chips right
here man
this is 10 cents a piece already
well yeah those were the one things i
remember like that was universal when
every school dinner we had in the uk
every
every kid remembers like [ __ ] dead ass
in primary school it was like currency
like you would like trade other food
items with people i think for smiling
i don't i think it's phased out now
because school dinners from what i've
heard in the uk
are a lot more healthy than they used to
be and that's because uh do you know
jamie oliver
yeah yeah so i think like back when i
was on a crusade
yeah oh really for like healthy school
dinners and apparently it worked
i'm jealous because i've seen some of
the school dinners that they get to get
nowadays
and man they be eating good they be
they're getting like a [ __ ]
three-course meal with like roast
chicken and all that [ __ ]
i'm just like dude the fanciest thing i
had in my cafeteria was uh
it was a chicken tender roll yeah
literally which is literally
a bun with two chicken tenders in it and
four dollars
bring bringing your own uh like lunch
like yeah i always do packed lunch yes i
used to for a while i don't know why
i had cause i had school lunch and i had
packages for some time i don't know why
i didn't didn't
but i remember i used to like trade do
you ever trade stuff with the other kids
yeah because your mum put stuff in your
box and you're like well i'm not what i
don't like this but
that guy likes this thing yeah i want to
try i always
used to trade uh like kitkat for cheese
drinks i like cheese string but
oh cheese string i remember cheese
strawberry yeah yeah yeah yeah because
i'm not being funny
obviously i love kitkat but frankly
eating a cheese string as a kid is
probably one of the most enjoyable
things oh yeah of course you know still
to this day i still really enjoy the
process if you think she's
i think it's very satisfying um and i i
traded
always always i traded my my like kit
kat for this
this kid's cheese strike and then when
my mom just asked your mom to get cheap
well because i think actually that it
can't this is going to be big
i think actually the the cheese string
is actually more expensive oh really
and the kitkats in the packs the kitkats
are pretty cheap that makes sense yeah
yeah there was like these like the
branded cheese strings as well yeah
like the cheese strips when i told my
mom i felt like
i like never saw her like weirdly upset
about something where
she i was like man why are you upset
about me trading stream so you could
have told me
what did you tell me and i'm like i
don't think it's a big deal i'm out here
hustling mom it's funny like
i got it it's like do you think we can't
afford cheese street
cheese string i'm like i like i like the
hustle it's fun okay i like trade
i like it i'm a businessman i've read
out of the deal
come on let me let me let me be i liked
it it was fun
it was fun scouting out what everyone
else had to be like trey
trade off
i don't know it was a kid for some
reason i didn't have any like qualms
about going up to a kid
i like that we should trade what do you
think oh yeah of course
and then sometimes kids will be like i
feel like they didn't they wanted the
trade but they were skeptical as to why
i wanted the trade
what's wrong with it what did you do to
the kitkat
i just want it like yeah i don't know
con you got a reputation for hustling i
don't know